diese sendung wird ihnen präsentiert und
präsidium verfeinert mit crème fraiche
mild und cremig residenz ihrer france
[Musik]
[Applaus]
chur am 12 februar 2020 es beginnt ein
historisches ereignis
ja
[Musik]
am 8
ich glaube dass er gewisse spanische
birne funktioniert so mehr platz und wie
genau cora starb wenn man sein
[Musik]
insgesamt 35 verurteilte verbrecher
werden verlegt mörder vergewaltiger
bieler bibel betrüger
[Musik]
angst haben die nötig glaube das wäre
aus der falsches falsche gefühle nein da
bin ich sehr zuversichtlich dass das
klappt mehr auf gleis eins wohl
mit dem umzug von curasan hof ins neue
gefängnis katz ist ihm jetzt schlägt die
schweiz ein neues kapitel im
strafvollzug auf
[Musik]
wenige monate vor dem umzug besuchen wir
zum ersten mal das gefängnis am rande
der altstadt von chur
seit 200 jahren sitzen straftäter hinter
diesen mittelalterlichen mauern
tagwacht ist um 6 uhr danach gibt's
frühstück
[Musik]
um 7 uhr geht zur arbeit jeden mittwoch
begrüßt schwester veronika die insassen
in hof alles wie immer und doch daniel
sonnental arbeitet seit über 16 jahren
im sennhof begrüßt das hundebiss neues
aber es wird immer konkreter konkrete
und jetzt es eben so münzer konkret die
einzige schmale stufen ins neuen das
ganze kennenlernen aber wirklich dass
man beide oder es muss doch wieder
laufen bis zum letzten tag gar nicht
zeigen also fertig und jetzt machen bei
den nachzüglern machen wir mit immer
eine ganz betrieb aufrechterhalten und
das bis zuletzt da bis zur letzten
sekunde muss es laufen
kaum sind die häftlinge bei der arbeit
überprüft barbara cola ob auch wirklich
keiner mehr in der zeller ist familiär
gemacht hat ich weiß dass er für wenige
worte aber sie auch sie kann es dem
entsprachen gut das ist vom sozialen her
muss ich sagen der familie
besser war als die sonne
wie soll ich sagen eigenschaft beträgt
ohne ihn aber es funktionierte da
unterstelle würde der ganze trubel der
dienstelle werden
weg.de hat eine dunkle gänge sich schon
ihr müsst sie käme ist
wir sind auch tag geschlossen darauf das
sind zum teil eingegangen
du hast einfach links und rechts ich
wand und technik groß fluchtmöglichkeit
ja das müssen wir schauen mit doktor
weil ich kann nicht mehr selbstbestimmt
barbara cola ist ausgebildete polizisten
sie entschied sich für die arbeit im
gefängnis wegen der aussicht auf den
umzug in die neue vollzugsanstalt cassis
ti
der sennhof ist über die jahre immer
wieder umgebaut und erweitert worden
eng ist er geblieben um 9.15 ist pause
im innenhof nichts grünes kein einziger
baum in der schreinerei arbeiten die
häftlinge am liebsten angeleitet werden
sie seit 20 jahren von ignaz fleck sie
arbeiten gerne hier besonders jetzt da
wir die möbel für die zellen des neuen
gefängnisses machen
das ist eine besondere herausforderung
und sie machen es gerne
fleißig
es ist schon ein besonderes arbeiten
aber letztlich sind es menschen wie du
und ich man muss sie auf der gleichen
ebene sehen wir hatten ja schon juristen
anwälte und alles mögliche
die jahrelang spieße gemacht haben und
es funktionierte tiptop aber es hat auch
schon andere etwa solche die getötet
haben man muss aber jeden als person
respektieren und nicht nur das delikt
sehen
[Musik]
schwester veronika ebnöther ist
seelsorgerin im sennhof regelmäßig sucht
sie das gespräch mit den häftlingen
die hand der zellen über problem darin
dass ich wenn sie irgend einmal konflikt
sie mit dem personal oder unteren an
teppichhändler sie bedrückt oder
belastet denn gibt's probleme mit der
familie daheim die freundin geldsorgen
es sind auch etwas wenn sie alleine sind
dass diese region eher leicht fühlen
oder platzangst ein und dann gibts auch
dir wo im glauben ihr in der frau kennt
wenn das ganze auch im lehr vom glauben
glauben sie und der kann
hilfestellung leisten und krisen geht es
im knast nicht aber für insassen aus
einem dutzend verschiedener nationen zu
kochen hat es in sich
eine speise geht immer
die tomate rief therapie kreis haben
einfach keine starken schmerzen
handelsraum
dreissig wichtig unser programm das ich
habe davon gehört zum guten gegeben
erklären um 11 uhr 35 ist mittagspause
[Musik]
der ganze tag ist durch getaktet jede
handlung der häftlinge wird kontrolliert
mit dem so gut wie möglich alles auf der
waage mit und wenn du nach einer
ursachen und sich freut
und der hund nicht gerade als jahr
später wieder zurück danke ist das für
isaac kurz oben
unter dem motto der stadt und der chefin
des hauses ist seit acht jahren ist ihr
job war immer anspruchsvoll doch
gegenwärtig leistet sie doppelte arbeit
mit 4 3 suite vom seehof und am schluss
130 mitarbeiter und dass sich doch jede
wieder im team sind und auch wohlfühlt
oder so sind joe borg am 8
ich glaube dass ich eine große
herausforderung und andere einfache
abläufe mir trainerteam sehen auf neue
übertragen auf die große stadt und dass
das wieder bradley also wie zara die
anderen auf die das gefängnis als
zukunft und chance
mit solchen slogans wirbt die direktorin
für personal interessiert dich am job
wohl eher macher der tantalus kabel
mehrheit vom strafgesetzbuch woher und
dort mitglied zimmer schafft es das mit
kollegen oder kolleginnen aber
selbstverständlich auch mitglied der am
rand von der gesellschaft sind wo es
urteile wohl aus dem nichts machen wo
nötig ist zum nachvollziehen dass man da
aber trotzdem schaffen wird und einfach
ein positives menschenbild das ist
wichtig stehen was die
gefängnisdirektorin sucht sind personen
die mindestens 30 jahre alt sind und
eine abgeschlossene berufslehre haben
insbesondere fähigkeit das marbacher
straffrei leben
das ist so ist die hauptaufgabe ist ein
alltag wo motor hängt also sehr
vielfältig sehr abwechslungsreich und
eigentlich kein tag wie der andere
wer sich auf da sie laute kriegte bis
zum schluss präsentiert sie eine
animation des zukünftigen arbeitsortes
das neue gefängnis in cazis teenies ist
sicherheitstechnisch auf allerneusten
stand
[Musik]
ines voller dort wird von der bündner
regierung auch zur direktorin des neuen
gefängnisses gewählt nicht ohne stolz
führt sie uns durch die anlage noch
bevor diese in betrieb ist
alles was alles zu viel aufregen
[Musik]
wir sind teil der medizinischen
abteilung im arztzimmer mehrheit büro
vor gepflegt aussehen gerade die
physiotherapie ihnen wo jetzt nur
gerichtet wird mir hängt sehr viel von
den behandlungsraum bis selber bei der
anstalt so dass man mit der insasse nach
öko will er sich personalintensiv zum
einen will muss mindestens zwei
mitarbeiter und begleiter und zum
anderen auch sicherheit nehme ganzes
gewährleisten daher war der
medizinisches watt wenn man nur aus
medizinischen gründen ebene haben wir
das tor machen sage mal zum zahnarzt in
mexiko zahnarztstuhl auch dass das und
extern zum zahnarzt sie richtig so dass
man möglichst viel auch heute weniger im
haus machen und noch einmal
dieses labor das mir all das mache musik
box in der spielstation katrin sass 25
miteinander wohnen eigentlich
zwangsgemeinschaft wege was sie hängt
doch sehen oder offen teils rum doch als
spielmacher norbert wenn es zähle
freigang hand & dogs immer letzte zelle
gang
die 25 zähler pro motor in die sind alle
glücklich gerichtet mit grund gab mal
eine zelle 20 machte türen auf die
erzählen ich 12,1 quadratmeter groß
mehrheit sie mit möbel vom seehof und um
real das wenn sie treibt der
schweinereien der vermachen rheumatologe
thema als lavabo sie hält es weeze
dienen
es geht ein tisch oder pc und fernseher
und vor allem immer sehr großes fenster
rote nase selber verleugnen so dass es
doch sehr hoch für freiheit geben die
fenster selber öffnen überzeugen
heute sind die einträge für licht aus
ist es hotel
aber wenn man werde alles vorgeschrieben
zeller bürger am morgen um viertel vor
acht dem gott der nächste morgen am 4
ab 7 widerruf und zieht einfach nur doof
und die marine bleibe und das läuft über
fünf jahre und der rechte wenn die dose
wie wirke ich doch dass ein zug der
freiheit größte andere person reinziehen
das neue gefängnis hat 119 millionen
franken gekostet
es hat platz für 152 häftlinge aus der
ganzen region ostschweiz
die meisten kommen aus dem kanton zürich
selbst einst der ursachen wird schwierig
genau die sicherheitsanlagen einen teil
davon nichts zu tun was ich sind als
erste nicht bestimmbare sicherheitszonen
detektiert 1900 nato darüber hinwegsehen
wenn sie nur sieben meter hoch aus ganz
italien kilometer lang und hinter der
maßnahme nichts tun als auch die
sicherheitsabstände momentan das ist da
wo man sich auf alle sind
[Musik]
im sennhof führt barbara cola weiterhin
kontrollen durch in regelmäßigen
stichproben sucht sie die zellen nach
drogen alkohol handys oder waffen ab
[Musik]
ja aber nur raffiniert gemacht sind da
natürlich die ganze nacht zum versteck
vor fantasie keine grenzen gesetzt es
schwierig zum projekt anhalt ist
versteckt ist oder nicht das tun ja
sanft sagte da der stau oder lassen sich
nicht so einfach abschießen stand
vertreten
das ist völlig egal verstand man sieht
man dass kinder gut verstehen
das wichtigste was er mitbringen muss
dass man authentisch ist und halt
mancher bernau das ist das wichtigste
kriterium in meinen augen und auch
flexibel und flexibel und der aber in
schwierige situationen kühlen kopf
bewahren wenn sie das antun willst
ja es gibt fast alltag schwierige
situationen meistern und das macht sie
auch spannend das macht es interessant
wo man dauer im laufe der letzten jahre
erfunden telefon stichwaffen medikamente
schauen wo sie versteckt wenn wir zum
beispiel das ist jetzt eine ganz normale
strecke aber auch peter stremmel da sind
das ideale verstecke und der tablette
broker und so wieder verstecken wenn das
wird zuerst das ganze 17 fuß so gar
nicht das dauert bis das ist ein insasse
wo der handys fotografisches gedächtnis
kann also dort hat wenn er die schlüssel
vom fc hat und hält sich eigentlich das
ganze schon amerika zeigt dass sowie der
schlüssel bad wenig macht ist oder oder
auch möglich sind was faszinierend ist
an der ganzen geschichte zu senken womit
gefunden hat ist im funktionsteam
schicksal und das ist sie sind es
vielfach einen schritt voraus und und es
geht afrika wo sie hand wo man organe
groß sind dass man solches könnte
als ich das tor ja das ist die weniger
schöne sitte da wo man den outfits der
tetra und strafschuss entweder der
karten denn die prüfer zeigt worum es
überhaupt da ist und ja besser als der
der nicht als manager sexy werder
gewinnt gegangen und dazumal und sich
nicht schön wenn man auch selber seitige
sache gerät zuerst ins einfach normale
praxis anno dazumal für mich und
wohnideen werde situation baby das sie
auch selber nimmt der h&m vor allem an
ermittler dann ist das natürlich einem
neuen verfahren sind beschließt
und das genau ist ihre aufgabe denn du
den schlussendlich dass man lagert das
sollte die sache aber nicht wieder gönnt
und schlussendlich oder die nächste
vielleicht auf eine andere bahn bringen
würde könnte die resozialisierung
jeder häftling muss sich mit seinem
verbrechen auseinandersetzen
dies geschieht in form von therapien und
gesprächen mit schwester veronika mit
psychiatern psychologen oder dem
sozialdienst die abgrundtief zellen
liegt auf zum teil und es erschreckt
es gibt moment was mir irgendwie das
befremden die schiffe aber erschreckt
als mini gerät immer wieder für sich in
großer broker also zeit und zeit bitter
aber einfach ihnen zeigen es gibt immer
eine frida sie das könnte sich
eigentlich es endlich anklage rache hass
dass ich für alles andere selbst
zerfleischen
alle zwei wochen versammelt schwester
veronika die insassen zum gemeinsamen
gebet und es ist sie liebt egal was sie
gemacht denn die bude regel aber einfach
investiere gemeinschaft mit dem was sie
haben und und dann hoffe ich einfach im
hof auf gott gemacht
ehrhoff war ganz ganz große liebe
das ist wichtig bedingungslose liebe
spüren geistlich almunia befassen damit
dass sie auch gefühlt bin von der bi und
so kann es weitergehen
liebig zum mensch und dass der glaube
dass sie den mensch in jedem menschen
verschüttet worden unzerstörbar ist und
wo nicht
der bezahlte vorträge dass das wieder
zurückkommt und blut und auch der glaube
dass sich vorstellen einmal mehr sein
eine solche betreuung wäre in der
vergangenheit undenkbar gewesen
daniel sonnental zeigt uns das gefängnis
museum so dass ich eine daumenschraube
dass gottes führt zu tag so und erfolgt
entweder mit dem dessert press die weise
wie wir das früher gemacht hat oder wenn
der schmerz größer gestorben
als natürlich das auch gemacht wo die
wähler aber das hat selber damit deine
lieder die das tut ziemlich weh
also ortsteil es ist schön dass uns noch
also vor allem für mich museum oder für
dieses museum
aber dort gibt es nicht
die handschellen und vielleicht sind
glitter früheren aber plötzlich flinders
es muss also 7
wir sind ziemlich oder so sind für
frauen sie das ich jetzt mit meiner eher
verbal oder daheim force fässler
romulaner kennt oder hand
britischen official vollzogen worden
sondern über jahre das urteil cv im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert ist die ketten
strafe abgeschafft aber die haft ist
weiterhin auf absolute unterwerfung
ausgerichtet diese bilder aus dem
zuchthaus regensdorf zeigen die
häftlinge tragen nummern statt namen
reihenfolge und abstand beim hofgang
sind streng vorgegeben sprechen ist
verboten
[Musik]
etwas mehr klarheit der heimatort der
vater da wo roma durchgesetzt hat zum
zweck zum beispiel also der hand ein
ziemlich zweck also dass hut nehmen
erlaubten auf werner cavlina
gummiknüppel darko mit dass dort das fiz
dauert also das hängt sicher auch nehmen
im betrieblichen gilt für das teile der
elektroschock anonymous laufen braucht
hat probiert aber das genau das führt zu
tag immer nach seit relikt von früheren
noch zu beginn des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert haftet dem sennhof der ruf
an der härtesten knast der schweiz zu
sein
[Musik]
die häftlinge durften ihre zelle nur
während der arbeit verlassen
sie verbrachten den großteil ihrer
strafe in isolation schlafen einfach die
hier herrscht diesbezüglich wohl
angenommen
ich komme vorgestellt das heißt dass
tokio sid dienste verpackt und dann noch
zwei zahlen
wie kriegst du gemacht und zwar schön
und das nicht immer geredet die
resolution ist ehrlich und nbc
[Musik]
das regime der isolation wurde erst im
jahre 2007 abgeschafft
jetzt da der sennhof seinem ende zu geht
scheint es als komme so etwas wie wehmut
auf besonders da es gegen weihnachten
geht
einige häftlinge basteln mit der
gefängnis lehrerin die
weihnachtsdekoration ihrem schlimmes
vorgestellt wenn man mit richtiger lüth
und so sich die richtigen rhythmus so
[Musik]
will man genau und spitze der bank
stehen clique zaun ist dass die länder
ab 14 uhr monika insasse vier türen
wie meinten oder anders ich habe mir das
irgendwie so wermuth nur froh
militärreform
viele filme mit der wille sich doch ein
störfaktor
es ist immer eine intime rahmen sich
meine rahmen wo abgeschlossen ist und
die glaubte gitarre emotionen gemeinten
oder andere so dass man doch sehr
getroffen mir und es bliebe
[Musik]
auch an weihnachten ist die überwachung
unverändert strenge aber für kurze zeit
werden die häftlinge zu gästen
sie werden bedient und aus der küche
kommt ein menü vom feinsten
[Musik]
unter druck geraten
mit zum dsc verlassen außerdem gelte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
berlin
si
[Musik]
im neuen jahr gehen die vorbereitungen
für die inbetriebnahme des neuen
gefängnisses in die endrunde
[Musik]
daniel solenthaler muss auf dem weg zu
seinem arbeitsplatz 15 türen öffnen
insgesamt zählt das gefängnis über 600
türen
[Musik]
die eigenen schlüssel und das handy
kommen in ein schließfach mit dem
gefängnis handy kann er nicht nur
telefonieren sondern per knopfdruck auch
alarm auslösen
[Musik]
ist diese juni formlosen polo shirt oder
hemd und der natürlich nach
wetterbedingungen regenjacke oder
softshell jacken mit dem wasser wasser
das ist immer das ultrabook das mit der
waffe pfefferspray einer taschenlampe
manager und da ist doch immer noch
vielfach der neue mitarbeiter sagen
einander die waffe unter sich gestreckt
[Musik]
in den schulungen für das neue personal
geht es vor allem um das erlernen des
richtigen umgangs mit straftätern der
schlüsselbegriff im norwegischen vollzug
system heißt dynamische sicherheit auch
hier geht es um respekt vertrauen und um
das schwierige verhältnis von nähe und
distanz zwischen den vollzugsbeamten und
den insassen
[Musik]
alles dreht sich um eine gute
kommunikation um eine kommunikation die
auf respekt aufbaut
wir schauen den insassen nicht als
kriminellen an sondern als menschen
eine straftat begangen hat daraus
entsteht ein dialog voller respekt den
brauchen wir bei der dynamischen
sicherheit punkt wo das system vor der
dynamische sicherheit an grenzen stößt
und damit erweitern endmärkten des
tanzen der lotterien source noch drachen
unsere technik und er muss das gesunde
mittelmaß finden wenn es nicht das drin
saß usa holt also was mir gewöhnt und
das kann natürlich auch als nachteil sie
und viele spieler mit dem spieler haben
sich damals gespräche das thema
ausschnitte wo man sich immer gut im
alltag und das sind unsere welt der apps
sind also wo wirklich okaz seeger montag
in das system einbringen und mit denen
haus oder schafe aber wir überzeugt der
wagen der honig und shooter mit trainer
sicher sie nach zehn minuten flachem
spielraum nicht selbstverständlich
gehört zur ausbildung auch das
regelmäßige üben der selbstverteidigung
und da kommentar angelina lecker zu
unserer sicherheit wichtig wie im
halbfinale kalorien sowie tabak wie
möglich will denn mit der handschelle zu
machen und es gibt keine druckstellen
die genussmittel mehrheit wäre mal was
mit ihr suchen und die sätze dass es
wenigstens gegenüber sprecher liu
jianchao tankstelle technik habe mit dem
stück das leuchtet der mond das
martinsspiel sache dort so dass man
damit über eine kultur dass es möglichst
wenig wie gott so sieht der trainer
ruhig schlafen
ganz langsam hapag hama stellt diesen
auftrag diesen auftrag lukrative sie
wischt resozialisiert und ich glaube
jeder von den insassen konnten oder
ihren noch bronze ich glaube wenn einer
ein hass zu für einen institution heiter
offenes system hätte auf eine staatlich
glaube nicht dass idee als nach profil
oder dem wir begegnen ihm im kopf wenn
der ganze hof braucht die schon
politikers messer oder wasser bier und
ein mehrere mitteile gekürt mit ihnen
teil vom staat system aber seit start
system eher unterstützend mit aller
konsequenz und alle grenzen was
selbstverständlich geht und über die man
nicht verhandeln
das war im sommer der weg zeigen die
beispiele auftrag und mit sehr niedriger
wie straff ist der freiheitsentzug
bestraft
einen tag vor dem großen umzug werden im
sennhof die insassen in den kleinen
spazierhof gesperrt das personal räumt
die zellen
[Musik]
jedem insassen steht eine kiste für
seine persönlichen sachen zu sehen ob
ich mir ans herz gewachsen es ist
einfach so vielleicht nicht verstaubt
liebe hat wird die letzten 16 jahre
anita verbracht und bin tagtäglich taxi
im jahr berichtet und sich nicht einfach
so tag fertig und wusste gedanken und
weg also würden sie seien hoffnung in
gedanken aber man muss aufs neue logo
und outfits trug steiler und ich freue
mich extrem aufs neue wo mit einem team
jetzt sein
abends um neun uhr zum letzten mal
werden im sennhof medikamente verteilt
[Musik]
nein die nachtruhe
dann ist es soweit am morgen des 12
februar 2020 fährt der zellen bus im
gefängnishof 1
[Musik]
im ort
aus sicherheitsgründen werden die
häftlinge in kleinen sechsergruppen ins
neue gefängnis transportiert bei einem
gefangenen transport besteht höchste
fluchtgefahr szenario im kopf was könnte
passieren und wer muss sie dann und dann
reagieren da macht man sich schon
gedanken dreier gfk befragte aktionen
gar mit dem mann hat im rechner
man muss die firma reflektieren wie ist
das ist es
[Musik]
gerade mal 24 kilometer beträgt die
distanz vom alten zum neuen gefängnis
und doch ist es eine reise in eine
andere welt
[Musik]
auch bei der ankunft geht alles wie
geplant und es folgen die üblichen
formalitäten
[Musik]
danach werden zehn jahre nach dem
entscheid ein neues gefängnis zu bauen
die ersten häftlinge in ihre zellen
geführt
[Musik]
als erstes werden die häftlinge in die
wichtigste neuerung eingeführt sie
müssen in zukunft ihrer persönlichen
einkäufe oder wünsche über das gefängnis
eigenen ex tätigen im sennhof lief es
über den persönlichen austausch mit dem
personal
neu ist auch häftlinge und betreuer
essen gemeinsam eine ganze namen wird
der bezug jetzt dazu den namen special
durch das sehr stockend und schluss
haben wir mehr natur schreibt für dieser
saison und setzte mit denen gemeinsamen
desto kurz vor allem gut dass rund
wieder so dir das für das was man
eigentlich sind die betreuung wurde und
das ist da so wurden auch selber
erfüllte man macht das so mehr erfüllt
das wenn wenn ich mit ihnen besser
machen und einfach nicht nur daube
früheren schlüsselloser zu machen und so
weiter also der zeit diesen längsten
sowie und jetzt eine betreuung im
vordergrund
der hofgang führt hier durch den
sogenannten checkpoint einen detektor
der alles anzeigt was die sicherheit
bedrohen könnte
ja
deutschland also wenn dieses auch
münchen sein können den ganzen tag wenn
die hallen wenn sie sanft über den
schambereich weil sie sehen in
deutschland überhaupt keine vorstellung
haben
aber wie gesagt im vergleich zu meistens
gibt auf
ich bin ihr gerät von 20 minuten als
stunden also besuchen
[Musik]
sind sowie zu ihren plätzen und
klassischer mit frischen dann ist es
nicht so dass sie für kräder
beziehungsproblemen aktion kongo ich
glaube setzen
zählt man doch
schön sport
das sieht schlecht das könnten die 5
ein schönes gefühl sie sauber sind und
uns richtig
[Musik]
derweil verlässt der letzte zellen bus
den sennhof wir wissen ganz stolz nach
dem 200 zwei jahren hoftor und
denunziert sich mit wehmut verbunden
aber schlussendlich auto bediener jahr
stellt in betrieb zu nehmen und im
betrieb für mich immer die seele und mit
leben fülle
und zwar mit lebe wo ein halt ab und zu
erfreut macht obwohl sie gemeint wenn
wir sägen umgebung war ein freund macht
und trotzdem so spezielle von der
anstalt dass ich im sennhof die neue
jahr starten
[Musik]
am späten nachmittag wird die letzte
zelle geräumt
der sennhof ist geschichte
[Musik]
vier monate nach dem umzug besuchen wir
erneut das gefängnis von graz ist im
netz
[Musik]
die bedingungen sind für uns dieselben
geblieben
wir drehen nur unter aufsicht wir zeigen
keine gesichter der häftlinge und wir
sprechen nicht über ihre straftaten
barbara koloss arbeitsplatz ist jetzt in
der sicherheitszentrale vorgänger kann
man doch bist wird es wird ablaufen aber
es ist für uns ein neues will
es sind genau alltag neu retro und
sukzessiv hat sich das oft parlament
legacy melika und wir sind einfach nicht
weg sie mit dem vermieter oder 200 er
und dankt ab jetzt immer den langsamer
voll und viele viele interessen immer
kant oder kann ihn nicht und das macht
es dann zum teil auch noch schwieriger
ist das hinterher dass es halt einfach
nicht mehr so familiär ist
[Musik]
jede ecke in cazis teams ist erfasst in
der gesamten anlage sind mehr als 500
überwachungskameras installiert
[Musik]
den anforderungen des modernen
strafvollzugs entsprechend gibt es räume
für therapien sitzungen und schulungen
ich bin an schiller müller ich bin 20
jahre art ich bin nicht verheiratet ich
bin ledig und habe keine kinder und
meine hobbys sind wir stark und ich
meine alles andere meyer
[Musik]
ich komme aus not ihrer in wedding
auch der neue gefängnisalltag folgt
einem immer gleichen strengen regime in
den hellen und übersichtlichen
werkstätten erledigen die häftlinge
auftragsarbeiten externer kunden
[Musik]
sie erhalten einen lohn zwischen 15 und
35 franken pro tag
[Musik]
in der sogenannten kreativwerkstätten
stellen sie geschenkt artikel her
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also zwei mal drei wochen groß
ja wenn das vollständig oder teilweise
möglich gefühl sie sind auch meditieren
mit wunderbare stimmung da immer so
etwas macht bisher druck dahinter
spielen sie minister lassen und dann gas
geben
mitte juli müssen schwarzen passiert
nichts
nein nicht die ist nicht so schnell mit
doch das ist gut gut jetzt noch mal
zurück sieht du schon knapp nein sie
müssen den knopf gedrückt halten
jetzt geht von alleine
weil ich nicht wusste
[Musik]
hat es überhaupt geht
[Gelächter]
sich auf eine arbeit konzentrieren
diese exakt ausführen und die vorgaben
des weltmeisters befolgen ist ein
wichtiger teil der resozialisierung
[Musik]
die galerie ist der seltene anno und mit
dem haben wir gesucht habe und das thema
steht wieder die sozialisierung sein
aber es ist von vorteil die musiker mal
helfen irgendwas zu hause kaputt ist
aber weiß halt stopp die niners gelernt
der gegend wohnen geschäften bietet mir
halt vielleicht die maschine wenn ich
sie nicht so schnell selber reparieren
gibt es sie wieder übers wortmeldung gut
ist das ist ja das genom spargel haben
nicht besser wir brauchen würde
ich habe pausenhof folgert die ein sehr
viel helau viel wie es dort viel mehr
platz audi vom sehr wohl lang im sennhof
geschaffen
ich habe es fast nicht vorstellen also
gut die haben diese fragen immer
charmant die institution bezeichnet
findet noch aber deutsches so hejl wer
gerne das gefühl dass man meine kenntnis
ist auch für die mitarbeiter am standort
soko und die insassen und justizvollzug
und insa sowohl standort so schnell wach
wenn ich hätte mir als sehr ruhigen
start zum einen ist sie hat die sehr
gute arbeit von der mitarbeitende
aber dort wo das gebäude ja unterstützen
es sind breit die kleinen beim uhrmacher
sich aus wie gruner hin oder her luft es
ist dienstag ein fenster groß öffnen
also sich glaub ich behaupte das gebäude
unterstützt
borlettis erst mal erlebt dass alle 100
mal vom normalen vollzug sei manchmal
offen platz sind deine quelle jetzt muss
ich anders auftreten muss sie wieder
zeigen dass sie immer eine gewisse sind
mikro tierleid chor funktion übernehmen
was sie mir auch einfach wenn ich sicher
bin oder wenn ich auftrete mia und
geschichte also irgendwelche stimmung
auf dem platz
dann können sie auch ihre trauer wieder
wenn es mir aussuchen
das verhebt die erkannt dass verträge
die magnet träger oder die hände bis
vermittelte bisher gekommen
[Musik]
früher im sender am wochenende 100
abstumpfende raus hier eine stunde
und das sind so annehmlichkeiten an die
man sich gewöhnt hatte inselhof das
waren bass und das hatte und hier wird
man beschnitten so genau auch die
annehmlichkeiten im sennhof wann kommt
die bücher bestellen um seine eigene
weiterbildung irgendwo voranbringt
konnte meinen büchern stellen auf seine
eigenen kosten abhängig
selbstverständlich aber hier ist es gar
nicht mehr möglich
und da das sind nur zwei beispiele
es gibt auch viele andere beispiele aber
bereich derzeit nicht
sein berufliches familie roxy stoff aus
dem atelier beleidigt
womit auch nützlich sondern auch
regierung
natürlich hatten auch aus dem bett
kommen
geduld muss man hier lernen
und hier keine geduld hat
ganz ganz schwer
zum schlafen noch einmal auf und die
gedanken noch immer nicht sprechen so
könnten einmal im laufen wie es wieder
weg sind auch noch handelsblatt aus dem
sächsischen was schade ist digitalisiert
und dem heimweg nicht so teilen und dann
kriegt man alles mit und hat vor noch
dann aber wir schaffen mit dem machen
und der tatsache dass die direkte
begegnung mit dem insasse unter vier
augen schweigepflicht und dass ich das
wichtigste man ihr so lanthaler richtet
die neu geschaffene altersabteilung ein
wegen der korona pandemie ein halbes
jahr verspätet
hier werden betagte straftäter leben
darunter auch verwahrte welche die
anstalt nie wieder verlassen und
vermutlich hier sterben werden
die philosophie dass man der gefängnis
charakter der beste weg bringt das heißt
das ist für elektrische türschlösser
meint dass man kameras mit überwachung
überall und so weiter aber dass wir mit
ihm nach und dass man sich wohlfühlt und
dann sind wir genau mit einem punkt oder
wenn tvo mit roots manuva gut also dass
man derzeit wohne da ist es ist auch
frühsport wenn man wenn man die person
so anbringen dass er doch noch ab
niederfrohna freude es machen und da
anders
also wenn er immer noch
sind zweirad dort mbt in der lieth und
warte bis der nächste tag und wie man es
von früher kennt noch irgendwie strich
gemacht doch wie lang es gelang es nur
dort und so weiter das ist es nicht was
es braucht seelig tor ihnen einfach als
limousine oder man muss trainer wohl
fühle und dass wir da sofort trägt sie
dass man dort einen konsens findet das
leben zu werten am 8
in so nem talas augen beginnt dies
beispielsweise allein schon mit der
beschriftung der zellen gut lesbare
nummern klingen den namen duster können
kuschel steht aber der freiheitsentzug
das ist das wo wir dort in völliger
türen und nicht dass sie dort in der mit
labour wir mit lauten der zieht es in
führung
aber das sind immer noch menschen oder
und da elektrolyt wodurch sind nicht als
klar weiß für jeden was für eine tat
gemacht hat und dass sie nicht einfach
die sache zum teil systeme sind und
dokumente und ja ganz seminar früher
einmal ein guter spruch also spruch
nicht an die wiesn von älteren auf see
ist das noch sie und der heckseite wie
die vier m kenne ja nicht wissen
damit meint aber die vier chemisch man
muss menschen mögen und dass gott der
mensch und nicht um das material oder
bis dazu gehört laut der
gefängnisdirektor in das häftlinge bei
tadellosen wir nehmen an recht haben auf
drei bis vier stunden privater
zweisamkeit
mit 210 erhält zwei stühle händen tisch
handys wc mit dusche und china hätten
wer rettet eigentlich an alle insassen
recht davon das zimmer es gibt ein paar
bedingungen wo man nur nach frühem
anzieht wie sie damit man darin sagt
kenneth und kennenlernen nach weiter
stabil liebe ca
also entweder karotte sicher oder
stabile partnerschaft habe oder was es
natürlich wenn man sich irren leserbrief
kennenlernt und das auf stabiles und so
wieder der hammer da beträge dass es
dass man das dorf benötigt ein teil für
der resozialisieren dass er im rosa und
auch eine stabile beziehung
das hilft ja dass man das wieder fuß
fassen dass man wieder im normalen
alltag leben sind die familie hat oder
vielleicht aber das inneren arbeiten
ein häftling im normalfall zug kostet
den schweizer staat 301 franken pro tag
und 406 franken im alters vollzug
in einer zwangsgemeinschaft wie dem
gefängnis sollen die verurteilten lernen
konflikte friedlich auszutragen
[Musik]
auch im gefängnis hat alles seinen preis
sei es fernsehen telefonieren brauchen
oder etwa die nutzung eines computers zu
schreiben so und was ganz wichtig ist
nach jedem waschen
damit stellen eingerichtet
ja aber wie gesagt das brauchen
[Applaus]
das gericht die schon mal freizeit und
ausgestiegen wie jeder mensch ist
sicherlich auch dadurch steuern einfach
so hohe familien alles sind das werden
sie aber gern hat dass ich das natürlich
erhält gut das muss man sich so
berufsziel
dort wird diese 18
ich werde mir eines tages anhören müssen
von ihr was zu der zeit wo ich die
gebrauchten nicht da und die muss mehr
leiden die ich momente wenn man über
diese dinge nachdenkt wie weihnachten
sozial und dann wirds halt
[Musik]
dank die habe 420 franken und habe dies
auch soldaten postiert sich dass der 64
meine tochter arbeitet jeden tag 30
stunden für 100 franken und im gefängnis
ich schlafe gut
[Musik]
die arbeiten der häftlinge aus den
werkstätten kommen in den verkauf um
deren markt tauglichkeit zu prüfen
besuchen externe ladenbetreiber die
ateliers mit der fräse oder weil sie was
das fasziniert mich also die kreativität
wie die mitarbeiter in den damit leben
in haft geschaffen zunahme zeige die
insassen geschaffen auch mit stolz sei
gut dass so eine präsentieren innere
kurz vorm wo auch noch wer die
wertschätzung gegenüber der insasse
daraus sie produzieren mit der
wertigkeit nach uster wo man sich wohl
für die bereiche soziales jähriger
wochen
unter einige szenen aus ja auch und
bild.de austauscht und allianz daraus
vorstellbar aber mit dem inneren beim
klaren regeln verdacht haben kann man
sich vorstellt dass noch sicherheitschef
gemacht
und wenn es gut dass die medizinische
glas lady kann man das ist das metall
ist der markt muss man ihr spiel war
gedreht weil man nichts gehabt
da machen wir einfach viel wert sind
egal ob es in sich
abstimmen viele frau so stehen wir wo
draufsteht beruflich nach meinung der
opposition und den zugriff und
unkontrollierten einfach wieder auf
[Musik]
so hält er für die blätter zum fixieren
das integrative stecken und je nachdem
man drin sein denn wir sind ein besuch
im cineplex geht man je nach dem was
besucher und dann informationen der 50
sie sehen wir sehen uns
martin
ja das kleine betriebe
medikamente fehlten doch nach unten
ein halbes ist erfreulich dass es geht
diese spezielle posten aber vor mir
eigentlich praktisch mit meiner frau den
tunesischen aber so schwarzbau steht im
verdacht den sie bisher stellen wir uns
vor mir und die masten auf und trotzdem
auch so wie sie ihre das ist geöffnet an
des dienstags wird reist der eltern das
macht ihm mut ist für die sicherheit im
gefängnis verantwortlich der ehemalige
schweizer guard ist und polizei in
struktur ist den ganzen tag auf kontroll
tour
naja
ja
guten morgen alles in ordnung so weit
jahr werden die sicherheitsvorgaben
eingehalten
ja da müssen wir dran bleiben ansonsten
müsste ich den betrieb schließen
die sicherheit geht vor und mit der
arbeit sehr gut
ich bräuchte nur mehr gute schreiner das
liegt nicht in meiner macht die bessere
zu besorgen
wer muss der sicherheitschef im griff
wenn zugriff junger gott und ich weiß
wer dich wirklich verbreitet dass man
der sache bezug auf gold und silber sind
genau das gibt allerlei gerüchte wo
morgen das kann auch spieler zwischen
mitarbeiter sieht es probiert zwar in
zwei mitarbeiter der genannten spiele
und da muss man sofort intervenieren das
kann man nicht akzeptieren
der sensibelste bereich sind die ein und
ausgänge barbara cola untersucht jedes
fahrzeug minutiös
während der kontrolle wird der
fahrzeugschlüssel sicherheitshalber
weggesperrt
[Applaus]
barbara cola versichert uns dass es
nicht einmal eine maus schaffen würde
unbemerkt aus dem gefängnis zu entkommen
das tutorial wert herzfrequenz darum
selbst ökonomen auf dem autos
kontrolliert in bussen sind kleinere
herzfrequenz ganz minimal
dann wäre man daher stetig zeigen
[Musik]
es ist august als lange solenthaler die
altersabteilung endlich eröffnen kann
einer der ersten insassen ist ein
älterer herr aus dem normal vorzug
er wird hier die letzten monate seiner
strafe absitzen bevor er nach italien
abgeschoben wird
[Musik]
dann werden sie hier unten in die seite
fiel der
[Musik]
angekommen sehr schön
nein so viel unterschied hat es nicht
oder wenig größer und leichter andere
aussetzen
jetzt dürfen sie alles hier und wenn sie
so weit sind sie können auch noch hier
das multimedia system ausprobieren oder
mal zur erde zurück machte und dann
genau ich bin schon einfach mal das ja
ausprobieren war es funktioniert und
dann kommen steht nochmals vorbei ich
denke viele der insassen haben noch nie
gearbeitet
deshalb sagen sie es sei hart hier für
mich ist es wie in den ferien die
aufseher sind freundlich aufmerksam
man kann sagen ganz außergewöhnliche
leute andere insassen werden die
altersabteilung voraussichtlich bis zu
ihrem tod nicht verlassen
sowohl kritik
die frau wurde in eine kurve fahren fern
vom mit der kraft dieser fahrer habe
sogar stimmen und jetzt noch mehr blut
durch gene von 1000 kubik
können worden
[Musik]
die
super
sie wisse was die dienste eines spiels
mit genannt macht hier bin ist da war
für yb
und da das alte personal auftritt mal in
ner branche gerichtet
und da hapert es mit dem hause der
schnitte so as me to hell zu werden
darum richtet ihren rechner schön und
werde die stimmung von friedrich
[Musik]
das problem ist gelöst
der staat ist erstaunlich einig es sind
sehr viele sachen eigentlich so
vorgestellt hat sind also getroffen und
vor allem das feedback von den insassen
rechts dahinter
wie sieht das eigentlich aufnehmen das
ganze hat das experiment gemacht haben
oder mit beschäftigen das ist vom ersten
tage eigentlich sehr gut die nach wie
vor allem musste noch nachsehen
und sicher besonders für europa wo halt
voneinander ich sage jetzt von einer
anderen verhängnis und muss halt alles
fleisch in der stadt den ex ist das so
die berge die regel dazu diskussionen
also ich habe einmal etwas anderes
wieder und das total gut
[Musik]
ich habe letztens punkt weil ich erst
mal wirken kann und darf es gerade sind
an dem tag reis ich sage sie was anderes
für mich wissen ja auch dass sie wissen
ja sie wollen jetzt nicht immer wieder
durch und dann rutscht natürlich kennen
darunter natürlich auch sagen dass das
man dann wirklich die hände hosentasche
behalten muss sowas würde man sich ich
sage jetzt mal freie natur
aber hier muss man sich sowas ja oft
auch zu sagen was zu müssen
dieser anruf erfolgt auf einer
öffentlichen einrichtung und kann im
rahmen gesetzlicher maßnahmen mit gehört
oder ausgezeichnet werden
vitalis mit klubs ja alles aber so
stichproben mit lose an astor läuft das
schon ein wichtiges instrument für ist
gerade im bereich rechtsgeschäfte was
machen unternimmt aber das kennt den usa
liegen wo der auftrag dem geld
überwiesen oder termine über zu lesen
und das können wir natürlich mit loser
und dann kam das auch verfolger wenn es
denn der fall ist oder arbeit rastatt
selber das unterland gemischt wird
evangelisches junko und wenn man mit los
das sind sehr zum 13
telefonisch über die führend warum frau
oder mit dem kind ja es schon aber ist
die spezielle situation wo natürlich
kann man nicht alles applaus aber immer
wieder so stichproben nach die
kinderlose auch films lag von ihnen saß
oder wenn er auf der wohngruppe druck
hinter laut dass es ihm schlecht
geworden begründet aus gegen ihm
schlecht und dann anhand vom
telefongespräch kann man das ein
bisschen nachvollziehen oder wie seine
gefühlslage ist dort dass die haie aus
mit thailändisches nachspiel dürfte
warum gruppe und das ist auch keines für
besonders hoch sind
je länger wir die direktorin durch das
gefängnis begleiten umso deutlicher wird
dass hinter dem hellen technologisch
hochmoderne gebäude ein strenges regime
geführt wird
jedes fehlverhalten wird mit verweisen
müssen oder arrest bestraft
nichts wird vergessen jede fehle
gefährdet den ersehnten erlassen des
letzten drittels der strafe bereits vor
der letzten zeile dieses jahr
geschrieben ist sich frei brauche man
auch immer jetzt die erste tour und
denke motori die zweite ihnen und das
wäre denn die sogenannte kunden kommen
deutsche disziplinarmaßnahme rom oder
inszenieren vor ein bis maximal 14 eco
machen
es ist aber auch maß also
sicherungsmaßnahmen über suizid alisch
dass man doch innentüren und genau der
forensik alibi politik zum fürs ganze
und dass man da einfach so hält dass es
sich nun trat nur wirklich sehr
spartanisch eingerichtet als einem
hektar soll und kaputt basler
sogenannten handys stehen
das pony auf der tischdecke zur und
taktisches denn und wird dass es wie
auch das wird oft beruhigend wenn man
sich vorstellt sie sind die vor 25
jahren gruppe unmöglich gegen 4.20
andere behaupten oder dem enormen dem
hushovd markdorf sich zu kaufen ich und
dann einfach wieder zu hoch und aber
hektar fernsehen und wenn er den grat
erbauliche die literatur für die bühne
so koran bibel oder süße bis dürfte sie
haben meistens nötigste tun was auch
verboten ist ist auch um für den
staffellauf den 23 stunden können auch
und nur während einer stunde aus dem
spazierhof fenster ein augenöffner als
ich aus
[Applaus]
[Musik]
früher oder später kommen die meisten
wieder frei die hat ist quasi wenn man
rauskommt
nach relativ langen jahren hieß es dann
irgendwo wieder anzunehmen
und da nicht irgendwo ein tiefes loch zu
versenken und zu sagen da ist er drückte
mich alles aus der fahrbahn zu kommen
und da muss mich um alles selber kümmern
und sofern der alltag draußen vorneweg
schon einigermaßen im griff magen lief
wird man das mit sicherheit auch wieder
irgendwo hinkriegen man hat hier nach
dem durch verlogene kriegt was man sich
wieder einprägt und festigt aber man hat
studiert bedeuten viel angst davor nach
draußen wieder zu kommen
[Musik]
dieser mann hat sein halbes leben im
gefängnis verbracht
[Musik]
wie ist das leben hier
jetzt zwei monate her
dann kommen sie wieder laufen
[Musik]
sie tönen ganz zufrieden 30 jahren
gestorben
dass meine million dass das ist das
lebenselixier natürlich
keller
wie viele der insassen wieder
straffällig werden ist nicht genau
feststellbar
viele von ihnen werden in ihre
herkunftsländer ausgeschafft wenn sie
die strafe abgesessen haben
[Musik]
der wiedereinstieg ins leben draußen ist
für jeden schwierig gewesen
das ist realität
und dann finde ich ist ein gefährt das
die leute draußen sagen wir leben hier
im luxus
wir dürfen nur was auch immer das
nachvollziehen zu können
die 130 angestellten von katz ist ihm
jetzt wissen nicht wie viele ihrer
häftlinge es draußen schaffen werden an
ihrem ziel diese männer auf ein leben in
freiheit vorzubereiten ändert dies
nichts
[Musik]
ja
wurde ihnen präsentiert von präsident al
gore verfeinert mit crème fraiche bild
und cremig president place de france